this week's 48 hours investigates the
death of a missouri snake breeder named
ben renick he was found dead in 2017 and
investigators at first thought one of
those prized snakes must be responsible
but they soon discovered his death was
no accident 48 hours correspondent peter
van sant has the story
on a hot missouri summer day in june
2017 montgomery county coroner dave
colbert was called to one of the most
unique death scenes of his 20-year
career someone being killed by a snake
is not something that happens every day
a literal snake pit a building with more
than 3 thousand exotic serpents
being nervously patrolled by a team of
armed sheriff's deputies
we're sure there's no snakes around the
victim
who aren't sure if one of these snakes
may have killed renowned breeder ben
renick who is being that's been running
but while examining ben's body the
coroner made a surprising discovery
ben's body lying face down hid the true
cause of death
he had been shot eight times once at
close range this was something that was
not just a
random act nearby was ben's wife lindley
she had found his body and had called
ben's brother sam renick to the scene
there's not a soul in the world that
would have wanted to hurt ben we
couldn't have imagined
anything like that but investigators
soon became suspicious of ben's young
bride they learned that lindley had been
unfaithful with two men
and she may have had financial motive to
want ben dead lindley stood to gain
millions of dollars from the death of my
brother between the life insurance the
sale of the snakes and the family farm
that she would inherit it was
significant yet with no witnesses or
direct evidence linking her to ben's
murder she would remain a free woman for
almost three years
until a jailhouse tip broke the case
wide open she walks in with a gun and
she just
shoots him a bunch of times and
leaves the witness claimed that lindley
shot ben with the help of michael
humphrey an old ex-boyfriend
but after their arrests lindley and
humphrey would both point the finger at
each other
who had really pulled the trigger
that's a good question peter van sant
joins us now peter what else did this
jailhouse witness say or provide as
evidence well this witness was another
one of her ex-boyfriends and he said
that lindley told him that she had tried
to poison her husband ben by making a
protein shake laced with narcotics when
that didn't work she went to plan b now
lindley says none of that is true i
actually brought this fellow into that
snake pit because i was going to tell my
husband that i wanted a divorce i was
worried he might lash out at me and i
wanted the protection and that this man
suddenly shoots her husband he says she
shot her husband and it all plays out at
trial wow and and the police when they
entered the house they must have assumed
that there were snakes on the loose they
thought there was a killer snake in
there because the brother of the victim
had told 9-1-1 a snake killed my brother
and we have body cam video it's really
something they're going around with
their guns ready to kill a snake i would
be as well peter thank you very much and
you can watch peter's full report it's
called the poisonous wife tomorrow at
night at 10 9 central right here on cbs
and on our streaming service paramount
plus